المسؤولون الإيرانيون يتوعدون بالانتقام
من الانفجارين التوأمين اللذين وقعا يوم الأربعاء في كمان.
كان الرئيس إبراهيم ري من بين الذين
حضروا جنازات الضحايا، وقد بلغ عدد ضحايا
داعش 89 شخصًا كما
تتذكرون، وقد أعلن مسؤوليته عن ذلك، وقد ألقى بعض
القادة الإيرانيين اللوم على إسرائيل في
البداية، كما قال وزير الداخلية
الإيراني.  وسائل الإعلام الرسمية أنه تم
الآن اعتقال العديد من المشتبه بهم،
وبينما رفض الجيش الإسرائيلي
التعليق على مقتل
شخصية بارزة في حماس في بيروت في وقت سابق من هذا الأسبوع،
أشاد سفير إسرائيلي سابق لدى الأمم المتحدة بأجهزة الأمن والمخابرات في البلاد
لاقتباسها
اغتيال القيادي في حماس.  يقول صلاح العري،
قاعدة حزب الله في لبنان، إنه يكثف الآن
الضغط على المواقع الإسرائيلية من أجل
وقف الهجوم على غزة، في حين أن هذه
الهجمات تجعل خطر نشوب
صراع أوسع في الشرق الأوسط حقيقيًا كما كان
دائمًا، وفرنسا هي إحدى تلك
الدول التي تكثف تصعيدها.  الجهود الدبلوماسية
لمنع حدوث ذلك في وقت سابق لقد
تحدثت مع وزيرة الخارجية الفرنسية
كاثرين كولونا حول الوضع،
وهذا ما أخبرتني به أن هناك
خطرًا حقيقيًا لتصنيف الصراع في المنطقة الذي كنا على
علم به منذ بضعة أسابيع أم هذا
المستوى من  إن التوتر مرتفع للغاية
ويتطلب كل جهودنا، وجميع الجهات
الفاعلة التي نحتاج إلى تذكيرها بأنه لن
ينتصر أحد في المنطقة، وهذه هي
الرسالة التي نقولها لجميع
الجهات الفاعلة المختلفة، نفس
الكلمات التي نحتاجها للسير على
المسار الصحيح وتحقيق النجاح.  تجنب التصعيد الذي
يشغلنا لقد تحدثنا مع
شركائنا الأوروبيين والأمريكيين أعتقد
أنك تحدثت مع الوزير
بلينكن بالطبع سيصل إلى
المنطقة اليوم أه لقد ناقشتم
إجراءات وزير الخارجية على ما يبدو
لمنع توسع الصراع
وكذلك  التصعيد يحدثنا من خلال تلك
التدابير عما يجب القيام به
لمنع تصاعد هذا الصراع،
نعم هناك العديد من
المواضيع التي تجتمع معًا والتي
لا ينبغي جمعها معًا والتي
يمكننا التحدث عنها في
المركز الأحمر، ونحن نرى
أنه منذ
أيام كثيرة جدًا  حوامل اليمن يهاجمون أم
القوارب التجارية ويوقفون التعميم
للقوارب وهذه
مشكلة دولية ومخاطر زعزعة استقرار
الشبكة بأكملها لدينا لقد
انشغلنا بها للغاية ونفكر
في اتخاذ إجراءات لقد
نشرت فرنسا فرقاطة في المنطقة ونحن
يجب أن
نتدخل أه ضد
الطائرات بدون طيار أم أه هوتي يجب أن نتحمل
المسؤولية عن هذا الوضع
وهدفنا هو
الحفاظ على أه حرية التداول حرية
التداول التي
قالت فرنسا منذ البداية إنها
تريد أن يكون لها استقلالها الخاص فيما يتعلق
بالقرار
صنع لكننا نعمل بالتنسيق التام
مع شركائنا